the question was how do we fix the
system when the system is so broken in
what seems like an irreparably
um
almost like you just can't even there's
no point in even trying and my my big
message to people all the time is go
local first start at the local level
like i can't change my country until i
change my state i can't change my state
until i change my county i can't change
my county until i change my city it all
starts in my backyard like if we can
actually stand up for the needs of a
local community and get that down and
get that on lock okay then we can start
to focus on our state that's like what
public square is the app that you built
it's like
what is it like it's like craigslist but
but more like um
more vetted yeah so it's essentially we
started a platform to help connect
freedom-loving americans with the
community and companies that share their
values so
we've been really disheartened by what
corporatism a big part of our system
being broken is that mega corporations
have gone kind of into the progressive
authoritarian world and partner with big
government in this effort to kind of
stamp out the small business world and
also the values that still tens of
millions of americans hold dear like
individual liberties freedom prosperity
and this has been evolving over the
course of the last few years and then
covet blew it up because you had
businesses all of a sudden literally bar
you from employment or even patronizing
their place of business unless you
agreed with their set of values related
to certain medical choices and so we
started this app that basically helps
people take local communities back
through the power of localized commerce
and so it's a social marketplace where
users can connect for free with all the
businesses that have agreed to a set of
values to basically say we're going to
stand for the rights and principles that
have made our country special in the
first place then they get discounts for
going there yeah and a lot of these
businesses so you mentioned the seven
principles yes those
yeah so when a business comes on it's
free for the business to join um right
now we've got about 100 new businesses
that are joining every single day and
they're loving the experience because
it's a great advertising source for them
for free so we don't charge businesses
we don't charge users we make our money
through advertising um that we don't
have to sell user data for which is a
big point in fact if you go to our home
page you'll see a transparency page at
the bottom of this so if you scroll all
the way down you'll see a little
transparency link at the bottom
this actually has our core values then
it also if you scroll down even farther
has the kind of tenants of our platform
that you know that you can trust as a
user and as a business
but when a business signs up they agree
with seven values that are essentially
at a high level we believe the
constitution is worth protecting we
believe in the rights of every
individual in the public square
especially related to health things so
no massacre vaccine mandates if a
business is on this app it means that
they will respect your personal choices
in that world these businesses don't
donate to any intersectional politics
meaning they're not going to yelp has a
big problem yelp last year came out and
gave free advertising to black owned
businesses wow at the expense of
everyone else isn't that of like illegal
it's yeah 1964 violation of the civil
act like civil rights activity
would that be title seven i believe
racial discrimination yeah sure yeah
yeah especially as it relates to even
employment i mean that's happening in a
big way right now so um a business
that's on the platform is not going to
identify themselves by their skin color
they're going to identify themselves by
the quality of the products that they
produce for their consumers bringing
this back to
supporting the free market of small
businesses to be able to operate with as
little government intervention as
possible which is big in a state like
california where it's impossible to
start a small business people people
need to share this public sq.com because
if you know we often talk about don't
give your money to people who hate you
you know jeremy's razor said that funny
line stop giving money to peop money to
people that hate you give it to me
instead yeah but
but transparent
but how do you find
more people like yeah you know jeremy
boringer or the daily wire yeah uh like
this yeah so if you live in an air and
you're like i don't know what to do well
here's one way to look up and if at the
end of the day you are avoiding woke
businesses and only going to people who
you know share your values then you are
shifting a massive portion of the
economy and power
into
better values you're spot on and and
like this shirt it's a great example i'm
wearing a shirt called rowan for
rowan.com it's amazing they didn't pay
me to say this they're not even a paid
advertiser but for rowan.com they're on
the app with a free profile this shirt
um they uh source their products
sustainably they're an amazing company
run by a guy that holds these values to
his core convictions um
it's his it's his world view to a t one
percent of all the proceeds that they
make off of their clothing go to
fatherhood so there's this national
fatherhood initiative that helps to
provide father figures for communities
where kids didn't have them it's like
these are the companies that i want to
support with my dollars not things that
are donating to blm with their corporate
profits and what's neat is that you know
we have 15 000 businesses on the
platform with the largest network of
these patriotic businesses in the
country and um the largest industries
are restaurants retail clothing and
droids small businesses that make our
country special because not only is
there like a yeah let's be anti-woke but
there's also like let's just support
small businesses in general because
they've been so hosed by what's happened
over the past few years the fact that
amazon gained in value over the last two
years
while small businesses are now in a
situation where 70 of them in the united
states may not be able to stay open
after this fall because of how hard
they've been hit like that to me is one
of the greatest crimes against humanity
i've ever witnessed and so
we're trying to support not only the
businesses that share our core
convictions so that we're not funding
companies that hate us we're also trying
to help just small business in general
because there's a need for it now today
more than ever what what about a company
that's in a jurisdiction that mandates
things like uh these businesses stand
against it in fact we've paid the legal
fees of businesses so they'll they'll
reject they're like yep unconstitutional
you're from chicago originally yeah
nene's deli great deli highly recommend
if you're in the chicago area um they're
one of our promoted partners they're
amazing on the app and they stood
against the mandates in chicago which
was nearly impossible they refused they
said the rights of our consumers are too
important we're not going to infringe
upon them and they got fined but we put
together a group that went and paid off
their legal funds and said keep fighting
the fight don't back down you'd mention
that you want to open uh source the code
at some point what's your timetable for
that great question uh
the desire would be in the next 12
months um but it's it's really hit or
miss it it relies upon a few features
getting done and us getting more
algorithmic based where there's anything
that you'd want to be able to use in
different environments so um that's a
great question like i could see like an
airbnb all the people that are airbnb
their house is also using an app like
this but not your app because it would
set up it would create new live maybe
new not liabilities for you uh if you
get into those markets um but that if
someone else spun up like a like a
public square
v2 or like uh you know whatever you want
to call it with that code and then you'd
have like a b and you'd have like a
like would you do you have rentals like
airbnb on there yeah we have housing
rentals so a lot of people have said hey
i wasn't a huge fan of how airbnb came
out and contributed dollars to
uh employees getting abortions across
state lines because that was a big
initiative that airbnb pulled about two
weeks ago and so we had a lot of rentals
on the on the app that said hey we're
here don't forget about us we're not
with airbnb come join us and we'll
gladly rent your house so there's um
absolutely there's an incredible market
for also like local bartering so people
that have just a single product that
they're trying to sell at a local region
that's great for them too
if you're in an area that's super rural
and there's not a ton of traffic we just
launched this nationwide six weeks ago
so we're
we're enjoying it and diving right in um
but it's been amazing the response thus
far one of the greatest
challenges is how do you how do you make
this critical mass enough for people in
hyper local communities that are way out
in the middle of nowhere part of the way
that we do that is also offering an
online marketplace you can also shop
your values in the online setting and
can spend money with the businesses
there that are agreeing with these seven
values but they'll serve you wherever
you're at in the country and so but
you're right in terms of how this can
have cross-functional applicability into
other environments the sky's the limit
um is it the kind of thing where i can
order like food from the restaurant
through your app not yet you'll be able
to absolutely yeah essentially it's a
directory at the moment um with a social
component but it will absolutely i mean
you should see where we're going this
fall we're starting to get more into
e-commerce you can actually purchase
right there and have it shipped to your
house from within the app itself right
now we essentially act as a directory to
get you to the businesses where then you
conduct and your shopping experience and
a lot of these companies will give you a
discount code for shopping there that's
the neat thing too is that me as a free
user i get a free cup of coffee every
week from a public square coffee shop so
it's really neat
i just signed up and i'm looking at the
local area and there's a ton of stuff oh
awesome i just signed up i went there's
a barbecue place and uh well i won't say
the city but there's a barbecue place
near here oh cool run by great people
highly recommend check it out what's the
name of it do you have the name of it uh
i'll say after the show i don't know if
you guys are cause it's about shout out
it's very close to you there's a lot of
businesses in really in the local and
local that's great check online because
there's
that's great news because we're in a
pretty rural area so when i when i when
i look on the map yep and it shows all
the little spiders yep the pins all
those businesses have agreed with us at
the time it's amazing they've come
through is there ride sharing uh not yet
but that's something we're super excited
about yeah we can't wait to it because
it's super easy to do the technology's
there um
yeah ride sharing is big bartering is
huge for us um a lot of these like
moving into the craigslist the angie's
world or angie's list market becomes
more of a reality in the near future
we're excited about what's coming what's
angie's list t-dog's barbecue yes in
charlestown oh
yeah they're on there yeah there's
another cafe that's there i went to
today pretty cool well i i i i you got
to understand this is my country where
yeah
yeah
yeah jessie small that would agree yeah
but you guys would know chicago i mean
the reality is the job board do you want
this to compete with linkedin or
something like that great question yeah
so that came about really as a sort of a
fluke we had a lot of businesses during
around the time that um the vaccine
mandates were coming out we had a lot of
businesses like hey i'm hiring and i
won't infringe upon people's rights can
you just put that somewhere and we've
had a lot of people get hired through it
and we've got an amazing partner in the
job board space called red balloon
that's helping do kind of what we're
doing but in the um in the jobs market
more more exclusively that's really
exciting andrew their ceo is a good
friend of mine and so we're partnering
together in a lot of our technology so
two things here first of all i remember
i tried to download um your app earlier
before it was rolled out i was very
disappointed that it was available
everywhere i'm very glad it's available
now the other thing is that red balloon
i looked at and they appeared to be
defunct which was very disheartening so
do you know if they're expanding as well
they are definitely expanding okay yes
yes and then what is the biggest like uh
roadblock you foresee for your company
it's a great question uh the biggest
roadblock is just we to be honest we've
got um a lean budget and a lot of
interest which is great news like it's
great that we're the largest entity in
this space and
praise god we've had a lot of success
thus far and that's solely because these
businesses have taken a stand and we're
grateful for it
but like that also creates a lot of
challenges because now we're building
the plane in flight and so anytime
you're building the plane in flight
there are just challenges with the
things staying together and holding fast
but if you go to like a city like
chicago you'll be amazed at the amount
of businesses we have a thousand
businesses in chicago like tim if you're
up there and you search that current
location bar
um
uh no x out there um go back okay hit
the current location bar see the current
location right above you oh a little red
bar what i'm not going to press that
okay oh no no that won't show your
current location oh it's going to be a
search bar let's see if this is one of
the things you're changing oh okay yeah
if you uh if you uh
uh if you go to that current location
bar and you search you don't have to do
it now but if you search chicago there
instead of your current location i just
want to show you an example of like a
largely blue city that has just blown up
chicago atlanta um phoenix san francisco
has done pretty well new york city is
awesome great yeah if you scroll over to
chicago oh hey detroit what's up yeah if
you scroll over to chicago and then you
hit search this area um just so you can
see like what a city looks like when it
really blows up i'm gonna go check out
my neighborhood i love chicago here um
let's see how we're looking so scroll up
okay now hit search this area let's see
there you go hey that's great oh my gosh
look at that and these are just local
ones so these don't count all the online
that service this area this is so cool
yeah it's really neat it seems like a
great way to help people feel like
they're not alone that's the whole goal
are you looking for investment at this
stage uh so we've taken just angel
investment um we're staying away from
all venture stuff
just it robs you of a lot this is
amazing thanks dude so i'm i'm in my old
neighborhood where are you at oh you're
right by midway and so the fact that you
can find businesses that share your
values in a place as blue and insane as
the south side of chicago yeah is that
it really indicates that the blue and
red is
i'm going to use this and go to these
businesses 100 i don't want to give
money to people who hate me amen that's
why we exist yeah and the deeper
emotional connection is i feel not alone
like we had it'll almost make me tear up
when i talk about it we had a lady reach
out we'd only been launched a month and
she said i feel we soft launched in san
diego and she reached out and she said i
feel like i have 6 000 new best friends
in my neighborhood like that was really
really cool because it was like it's
it's amazing to be able to shop your
values stop spending money from
companies that hate you go for all of
your life's purchases and feel good
about your purchases it's a whole nother
thing when you can feel like i'm not
alone anymore when i
when i look at an area in the south
burbs of chicago and you see a cluster
you know these people are all friends
they told each other like they
absolutely are yeah they're probably
getting customers
and part of the way we grow is through
an ambassador program so like we have an
amazing chicago ambassador and so the
chicago ambassador goes out refers all
these businesses to the platform
recommends them to the platform it's
really neat and so that's um that's part
of the way we grow it's very grass roots
we have a team of activists around the
country literally a parallel economy
that's the whole so great how do you vet
the companies like if someone did do vax
mandates how would you regret that so
we've had two instances since we
launched um at all even including our
soft launch back last october um we had
two instances where a user reached out
and was like hey i think this business
may have been with you at a time but no
longer is they just let us know and we
kept moving on so we pulled them off
okay off we go
yeah we're committed to the rights of
our consumers though and so if if a
business is on there and they got to be
with us and it's not it's not a
tribalistic thing it's just that there's
there's a constitution in place for a
reason we want these businesses to
respect that and um and consumers
deserve to know that i'm not gonna go i
remember how embarrassing it was like
covet i walked into a coffee shop and
got told to leave right away because i
wasn't wearing a mask like that's
embarrassing there are a lot of people
in there the last thing we'd ever want
to have happen is a consumer feels that
way and so
that's why we really do hold fast to
these values so how do you kind of how
do you kind of not enforce but encourage
people to adhere to these rules because
you're right these are great principles
but how do you make sure that they're
following through even like one year two
years five years for sure great question
we ask for consumer feedback on every
interaction that's a really helpful way
so if a user shop somewhere we ask them
to let us know how their experience was
um and you know again 99.99 of those
interactions are incredibly positive we
learned new stories through it um right
but it's it's everything too it's random
industries uh like we had a
office supplier from alabama joined last
week heard me on this tv show and um he
said hey i just want to let you know he
called me because i hadn't talked to him
in eight years but i know this guy
personally he didn't know what i was
doing now he calls me and said i just
want to let you know within 24 hours of
being on the platform i had an office in
ohio call me for supplies from alabama
and they're my new client oh my god and
they're one of our largest clients so
it's really neat to see like even the
way businesses are now supporting
businesses and that's cool like the b2b
side of this is limitless too so we're
excited to get into that a little bit
more you said earlier
ad revenue is how you make the company
makes money right now but you don't
track any data
we don't sell any user data and any data
we track is purely analytical and it's
not based to a user so it's basically uh
we can tell a business you got 8 000
impressions this month but we can't tell
you demographics who did it right the
gender any of that we don't even ask
users that i guess it wouldn't be
untargeted ads the ads are targeted
people that like the business of they're
targeted to the entire platform like we
don't have any ability to target other
than your region so we can tell you
chicago you get an ad that runs in
chicago but we can't tell you to what
demographics or what but if someone
likes browses a lot of restaurants do
they get restaurant no not yet no and
even when that comes in it'll be user
preference driven it won't be a hidden
algorithm so
what will happen in the near future in
uh the beauty of building the plane in
flight what'll happen in the near future
is that when a user signs on they'll
actually tell us what they're most
interested in so i really like
restaurants i really like coffee shops i
really like clothing companies i really
like graphene and then and then what
will happen is that what you'll see will
be most catered to what you told us but
you can change that at any time are
there categories can i say like show me
your restaurants yeah yeah yeah oh wow
yes if you scroll down i'm totally doing
this like tomorrow for you or something
so if you scroll down um
uh you'll you'll see categories so you
get a normal category so that's in
chicago and now you're in a region if
you go to shop online you'll see like
there's a
a whole list of categories if you scroll
down um you'll see all these yeah
yeah if you want jewelry if you want
clothing you want retail you want tech
services you have made it very easy to
stop giving money to people who hate us
that is music to my ears that's great
news i'm very glad to hear it's not just
about not giving money people hate you
about giving money to people who who
like you yes yeah big time that is what
it's about and it's impressive you did
it with a small team thank you like you
said you it was just a couple a couple
of you started it off yeah we're now
we're now at about 24 people on our head
count that's impressive thank you thank
you it's been a lot but it's been
incredible that's in like a year was
that in a year you went from yeah we
wrote our first line of code 13 months
ago that's so neat wow did you just get
struck with the idea yeah it we needed
it it you know i have a lot of respect
for business owners that start
entrepreneurial ventures because they
see a hole in the market there's a whole
other level of fulfillment when it's
something you personally have felt and
my wife and i we
we felt the covet thing hard i mean we
just felt so disheartened by what was
happening we made a list of all the
businesses in our local region on a
piece of paper that we knew we could
support because we knew the owners we
knew they would stand with us
so it came out of a lot of personal
experiences the desire to feel connected
to people and not alone
because you can feel that way especially
in california and so what about
businesses that might be services with
no physical location right yep yep those
are on there too plumbers electricians
financial advisors
we got it all would that pop up on the
map or what are they uh they'll pop up
on the map if they have at least like a
focal point that they'd like to service
um but then they'll also pop up in the
category list without maybe necessarily
a physical pin on the map if they have a
surface area but no physical location uh
yeah it's really neat
wow that's so is there like a woke
version of this they have that don't
yelp yeah
all of
next door them
all of them yeah wow but you're right
though it is it is for us like we get
asked all the time why don't you create
this big blacklist and tell me all the
companies i should hate and it's like
because that's that's evident that's out
there like we'd much rather focus on the
positive here's where you should go like
it does mean no good to tell you
i mean it does do some good knowledge is
power but like you know chase and bank
of america don't like you what i would
rather do is tell you about access which
is like an incredible freedom-loving
bank that holds fast to the constitution
and they'll serve you anywhere around
the country access bank axos great check
them out they're amazing axos they're
based out of san diego x os clothing
companies like pharrell and i'd rather
tell you about this because it's hopeful
it gives you hope in the country i'm not
a big fan of the don't give money to
people that hate you because i don't
think they hate you they just don't care
about you i'd rather complete money to
people that like you yes and support
your ideals yep exactly that's why we
exist i'd rather give more money to
somebody you know serving food
who was cool and was nice and supported
what i supported as opposed to literally
anybody else what ian said i think there
are a lot of business owners who
if they knew your political leanings
would like kick you out of their
businesses there are ideologues out
there and when i walk into a business
that has like blm flags and
like the newest updated lgbt flags
everywhere
all over the walls more than their own
branding i
do think that it's meant to deter
anyone who's not woke from entering the
business and supporting it
yeah might be something in that yeah and
on our vacation it was terribly sad
because i had somebody say to us if i
had known that you weren't vaccinated i
wouldn't have invited you and i was like
crushed i was like crazy oh it's so sad
it's horrible they're locked in a weird
mind statement and that's what tim talks
about the cult and i wanted to say in
october of last year we were talking to
this big crowd of people we had at our
little event and i was like you know
what you guys should feel like great
about this because this
tells you that you're not alone like
this is something really impactful and i
feel like this app is the perfect
representation of that that's so
exciting yeah thank you that means a lot
yeah
we do i love it do you have venues on
here like oh yeah we have a really cool
art collective venue that just joined
from san diego highly recommend i can't
even remember their name but if you look
in venues and cities we have a music
venue in indiana that just joined like
really cool
yeah
it's awesome yeah because that was a big
thing during covet there was a big
vaccination push for music venues and
some bands required it not even because
of their personal convictions but
because the venue required it and so we
wanted to kind of counteract that as
well thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there